yes brief through it cardi oh
cardi B shows off her impressive
flexibility skills as she trains with
Fitness coach Wade Bryant so here's the
T the former dancer revealing stretching
is a key component of her new workout
Journey
I've been working out on my own for a
month
but yesterday I started a stretching
with Wade for an hour and then I started
working out for two hours with pleming
shy and I'm dying today but I'm still
gonna keep going ain't no quitting over
here and when we see the progress in one
video cardi goes for a split with the
help of her coach and some yoga blocks
and then she attempts a leg hold
seemingly shocking herself with how far
she was able to lift her leg oh snappity
snap snap but in the next video you can
see Cardi's hard work paying off because
this time she was able to take the split
even lower and point the toe oh yes
honey the mom of two has never shied
away from sharing her body Journey with
the public even revealing the nips and
Tucks I really want to explain to people
how hard is the process I feel like a
lot of people look at girls on Instagram
and think like oh they got the lapo done
and it was so easy and this is such a
long hard process it's almost like the
same process as after you give birth to
a baby and you've seen your body change
and snapping it back along with that
lipo confession she opened up to ET
about getting her breast redone after
giving birth to her daughter culture I
feel good and then sometimes I feel like
nah you know what I'm saying like your
your skin is like more stretched out yes
my daughter me up
four years later and Cardi's still all
about going under the knife explaining
why to Jason Lee people will be assuming
that like when you do surgery or
something like you're insecure about
yourself or you hate yourself and that's
just not the truth I like being perfect
I like a certain type of body like for
myself one made in the operating room
and in the gym
[Music]
foreign